the inquest into dawn sturgis is now
going to be converted into a public
inquiry this is something that has been
uh pushed for by the coroner baroness
heather hallett on the grounds that the
remits the fiat of the inquest wouldn't
really be able to get to grips with the
questions that need to be answered into
the death of dawn sturges she was 44
years of age
she was a mum of three she became
seriously ill after coming into contact
with novichok and subsequently died now
the question really that needs to be
answered is how and why did that happen
now obviously the inquest could look at
some of that but some of the material
that they need to look at some of the
testimony is extremely uh sensitive
given that there are accusations being
made against the russian state and its
alleged involvement in the poisoning i
think the other big question that needs
to be looked at
quite firmly in all of this is the
timings of course this revolves around
the poisoning of sergey skripal a former
russian agent that happened in march
2018 his daughter yulia also poisoned as
well but it wasn't until june uh that
dawn sturgis became ill and subsequently
died now it's thought that she became
ill as a result of novichok which was in
a perfume bottle it's thought it was
found by her partner charlie rowley
somewhere in the city but there's a
three-month gap there what happened to
that novichok where was it exactly found
was the novichok in another vessel
during that time now all of those
questions are going to be things that a
public inquiry
can focus very firmly on
what happened
why did it happen who was responsible
for it and what lessons can be learned
now it should be said that there are
three suspects in this case wanted by
the metropolitan police all of them are
believed to be in russia at the moment
there is no extradition treaty uh with
that country so that the chances of
there being a criminal trial into all of
this are extremely low the russian state
for its part vladimir putin denies any
involvement in this he says the suspects
were civilians despite strong evidence
that they were a member of russian
intelligence
the
inquest uh itself will now obviously be
converted to the public inquiry and
according to the the home secretary
pretty patel she hopes through
greater understanding it will give some
comfort to the family of dawn sturgis
and it's expected that it will happen
sometime next year